so now we're going to dive into the
flight environment
all right so the first part is flying
actually let me just pause there were
there any other questions about about
the charts and the airspace okay good
they're kind of related to the flight
environment so feel free to jump in here
all right
so flying so there's a fair amount of
work that a pilot is supposed to do is
actually required to do before they fly
so you're supposed to become familiar
with information that pertains to your
flight and in fact it's a very good idea
to do so that's exactly how you become a
safe pilot so it's important to
understand information related to your
flight so you know there's not only the
airport that you're taking off from and
when Phillip talks about performance
you'll talk about the length of runway
that's required but you also want to
know about alternate airports along your
route so you know if I'm flying from
from here to Maine for example you know
there's a lot of airports around along
the route I'd want to identify a couple
along the way understand what the
weather forecast is for those airports
whether or not they have fuel those
types of things are very relevant to
know you're also supposed to understand
you know how much so we talked about so
when you talk about aircraft performance
you'll understand what length of require
unweight you require in order to land
and then you want to make sure that the
airports that you've identified as
alternate airports along the way have
long enough runways for you to land so
let's talk about some of the paperwork
so there's this acronym arrow that's
supposed to help you remember the types
of things that you're required to have
inside the airplane so there's an
airworthiness certificate registration
if you're going on an international
flight you need a radio license it's
actually pretty easy to get so if you
wanted to fly from here to Canada you
only have to pay $60 you get your radio
license and you can go fly to Canada so
it's great and also the international
language of a
his English so even if you go to
Montreal you don't have to learn French
you can speak in English and land there
so it's great
so oh is the operating limitations those
are displayed in various ways such as
your your flight manual and placards and
we'll give you some pictures of placards
so you see what those are and then
weight and balance information and we
have a whole talk just about calculating
weight and balance when I think tomorrow
so operating limitations so these are
real restrictions on the aircraft in
terms of what it's a maximum feed speed
you can fly with and without your flaps
extended and which kind of procedures
can you do and we talked about certain
aircraft that you're allowed to do these
fancy aerobatic procedures in an other
aircraft where that's not a good idea
because if you really push your aircraft
to enter a spin it may be very difficult
to recover from it and so there are
different things so one is called the
the poh or the pilots operating handbook
and I have a poh over here and it has a
lot of great information in it so pretty
much everything Phillip taught you about
aircraft systems is is in this book as
well it tells you about everything about
your your airplanes systems its
requirements its restrictions and how
you calculate the runway length that you
need to land and your weight and balance
all that information is inside these
books so this is an example of some of
those limitations for an SR 20 as an
example we're talking about serious
aircraft and so you can see the same
types of numbers that Philip was
pointing out before the different V
speeds and you can also talk about these
manoeuvrability limits as well minimum
flight crew for a lot of these small
airplanes is usually one but some of the
very big complex airplanes and and jet
aircraft require the co-pilot as well
and some airplanes even require another
crew member as well so there's certain
aircraft instruments that you require
when you fly so they call they're called
Inc equipment requirements so a VFR de
which is visual flight rules so
a nice sunny day no clouds so you'll be
doing VFR your entire time getting your
your private pilot's license except if
you do a couple days of instrument
training but vast majority of time
you're talking about a VFR flight so
what do you need you need some of those
key instruments we were just talking
about your airspeed indicator your
altimeter a compass and then a couple
things related to the engine so you
understand about the engine its oil
pressure temperature and you need to
know things about your fuel and a lot of
them have alternates you could measure
your fuel from different ways but
somehow you must have a fuel gauge to
know how much fuel you have you also
need to have anti-collision strobe
lights that kind of go off and seatbelts
who knows what an ELT is yes that's
right and so that that Emoji emergency
it's an emergency device that basically
activates when your aircraft if your
aircraft is under duress and as a
descending very rapidly it goes off and
admits your location out so that people
can come and find your aircraft very
quickly there are also some in these
numbers by the way at the top in case it
wasn't clear our regulation so their FAA
regulations so ninety one point 105 is a
regulation about pilots you know sitting
in their seat when you're flying the
airplane so for all practical purposes
when you guys are flying you have to sit
down and feed the pilot and fly the
airplane this isn't like a big
commercial jet where you're gonna get up
and start walking around so you need you
need to basically sit down seatbelts I
as a pilot and command you you also get
to make the rules for your flight so if
you think you have some kind of rowdy
passengers you just tell them the the
rule is you must wear your seatbelt at
all times you know the the actuality is
that there are certain times and
restrictions where it's required so taxi
takeoff landing is required to wear your
seatbelt but you can extend that rule
and say at all times you must always
wear your seatbelt
there's also an interesting regulation
that says that passengers can't
interfere with the crew members but I
will point out that depending on who
your passengers are they may or may not
comply with that regulation we already
talked about the different altimeter
settings so kind of it can be the case
that you instead of being the the
perfect condition of 29.92 it might be
the case that you need to adjust your
altimeter to that local setting so you
can we talked about ADA swear you can
dial in the frequencies of the ATIS and
it announces the the weather information
for a particular area they will provide
the setting that you need to set in that
window so they'll say you know twenty
nine point nine eight or whatever is the
altimeter setting also if you're flying
over a bunch of places and you're
talking to air traffic control they will
update you you know they hand you from
one air traffic controller to another
air traffic controller one of the first
things they'll tell you is what is the
altimeter setting for that area so that
everybody has adjusted it everybody
knows what altitude they're at so
there's a little knob on your dial and
you turn it until that window on the
right says the right number now if
that's not available you already have
some information which is Airport
elevation so also on those things being
passed around for a given airport it
tells you what the elevation is so for
example if you're if you know that the
airport is at a you know 100 feet
elevation you can just and you're
sitting on the ground in your air in
your aircraft getting your airplane set
up before you take off then you know
that you're at that you know hundred
feet so you can just keep turning the
dial until it says 100 feet and then
that'll actually give you the the
setting in the window
you know there's some restrictions yes
go ahead
so that that happens a lot so you can
basically look at the the nearest the
nearest airport is probably the best way
and those are the times that you really
want to keep in mind what Philip was
talking about that if you are going from
a hot place to a cold place you want to
keep in mind that hey I might actually
be descending even though my altimeter
says I'm not but in general if you have
a local setting that's nearby you're
pretty much good they don't they don't
vary dramatically unless the weather is
changing a lot in which case you really
shouldn't be flying because it means
there's a huge front coming in so here's
an airport diagram a lot of information
here but one thing so this is actually
bedford and so you can see a couple
things you wouldn't see at other places
such as the US Air Force ramp that's not
going to be at other places but you
basically see these two intersecting
black lines so those are the the main
runways and each runway is
bi-directional so on on one side so it
says the numbers very small right here
next to the mouth say 11 so that's
runway 11 and then on the other side it
says 2 9 so basically if you land in one
direction it's one number if you land in
the other direction it's another number
and that number is corresponding to the
heading of that runway and then you see
a bunch of lighter grey lines so those
are the different taxiways and there's
all kinds of stuff here I won't go
through everything but one thing that's
really relevant is this acronym here and
it kind of looks like lasso but it's
what it's saying is the land and hold
short so if you're given an instruction
so when you have two intersecting
runways they might want to keep up the
efficiency they might want to have you
land while they have another airplane
taking off on the other on the other
runway and so there is a line that says
that if you are given a land and hold
short instruction that you're supposed
to land but you're supposed to hold
short you're not supposed to cross the
intersecting runway because there's
traffic on that
way things did everyone get the the iPad
to look at the sectional okay great yes
on sectionals I was looking at the hands
to area and I could not see anything
indicating the airforce base is getting
special symbol are there special symbols
for military sites that do have their
branding yes so that's restricted
airports for example so they have a
different color and different symbol
around them that would indicate that
they're a restricted Airport one thing
that's kind of interesting is that even
though hands comes at an Air Force Base
does it have any particular restrictions
so you just get a nice private airport
that you can land at that has
ginormously long runways so it's just a
great training Airport so Phillip I just
went ahead into the flight environment
so taxiing in the wind so this is what
do I mean by taxiing so you must have
heard of this on commercial aircraft so
this is when you get from you know in
that case the jet bridge out to the
runway but basically as you're as you're
driving along the different roads at the
airport that are not the runway the
taxiways as you're doing that there
could be wind in general as we talked
about with with regard to lift earlier
in the day you know you like having the
wind coming at you and we'll get into
performance and why it's really bad if
the winds coming from behind you but
usually the run the wind will be coming
down the active runway they decide which
runway is active usually by the wind
direction so there's a lot of wind going
on and you're when you're taxiing to the
runway you're probably going in
different directions with respect to the
wind so one thing that's important is to
think about while you're taxing you have
to make certain corrections to your
aircraft's controls so to the the rudder
and to the ailerons and the elevator at
the back and so when you're taxing on
the ground your rudder is used to
actually make turns on the ground the
ailerons and the elevator need to be
turned in such a direction that
basically results in your airplane
staying on the ground
inadvertently being lifted up by a gust
of air so in a true this this airplane
is what we call a tail wheel because
there's a wheel back here at the tail so
it has two wheels up front and a tail
wheel in the back a tricycle-gear
airplane would have one big wheel up at
the front and then and then two wheels
so three wheels total but the instead of
a tail wheel it has one wheel up front
so in this case a tricycle wheel so not
like this but with a wheel up front what
you want to do is if there's a
quartering tailwind so when wind coming
from behind you from the back you want
to dive away so you want to turn your
ailerons away and you want to push
forward to dive away from the wind and
if the wind is coming from the front a
headwind you want to actually kind of go
into the into the wind with your aileron
and you want your elevator to be neutral
so instead of pushing in or pulling back
you just want it to be neutral it
doesn't matter as much for heavy
airplanes but for literal airplanes you
can get bounced around and so it's it's
slightly different for a tail wheel so
it's good to figure out which type of
airplane you're training on and get used
to how you would make those Corrections
as you're taxi there are a lot of runway
markings and taxiway markings well the
thing I would really encourage you to do
is that the next time you're on a
commercial flight get a window seat and
look out the window and you can see all
these all these markings as you as you
go along you might be able to identify
which runway you're taking off on and so
I won't go through each of these the the
actual runway is this red number so why
are there two numbers why does it have
15 and 33 that's right because runways
are bi-directional so depending on which
way you're taking off on it or which way
you're landing on it it could be runway
one-five or runway one three the the
yellow ones are talking about you know
there's a difference between whether
you're on the runway or on the taxiway
versus it's an arrow pointing to it
somewhere else so you know this sign is
on the one that you're on
and this one is saying so your if you
see this a like this it means you're on
taxiway alpha if you see it like this
with an arrow it says you know that that
way to taxiway Bravo it's very important
that you do visual scanning so you
really look around for other airplanes
so when we talk about visual flight
rules VFR which is the vast majority of
your time on your pilot private pilot
you need to be looking outside the
airplane to look for other airplanes to
avoid and it's unfortunate but actually
most midair collisions occur in your
airports and good weather so if they had
been looking out they could have seen
the other airplanes so when we were
talking about the pros and cons of low
wing and high wing I was very focused on
your visibility so where you're looking
in terms of you want to clear before you
make any turn you want to look before
you go in fact mark Nathanson the FAA
examiner who's coming tomorrow that's
the probably the easiest way to fail
your FAA exam he'll tell you to do a
maneuver and you just start doing it
fail you have to first clear the area
you might even do a clearing turn so
turn in one direction and turn the other
way because you know your wings are kind
of obscuring you so that you can look
all the way around make sure there no
aircraft in the vicinity and then
perform your maneuvers but of course you
can also talk to air traffic control and
other folks to get traffic advisories
will tell you hey there's an you know an
aircraft at your 3 o'clock and you know
5 miles ahead of you those types of
things are very helpful they're not
always required but they're recommended
so before we talk about right-of-way I
thought I would just challenge you with
a question who do you think has the
right-of-way a blimp
an aircraft refueling another aircraft
or a glider
so we're just gonna we're gonna do a
poll so how many people for blimp we've
got about 20 people for blimp okay how
many people for aircraft refueling
another aircraft I was almost the same
number 20 people on an aircraft
refilling another aircraft how many
people for glider ok glider has the
majority of the the classroom here so
the the majority of the classroom wins
it's the glider and this is a very
complicated question obviously you would
never be in a situation where a blimp on
an aircraft refueling another aircraft
and a glider all coming together head-on
but the yeah
so the the glider wins because it is
unpowered and and so unpowered aircraft
have a priority over all powered
aircraft however if you're in a if
you're in a glider and you see a blimp
you know those things are slow i really
suggest avoiding it anyway so they're a
bunch of right-of-way rules they're all
described in pharr 91 113 and so
basically talks about the the order of
operations and kind of the big things to
know is that if if anybody is in
distress or has an emergency they
usually just get priority over everybody
else balloons
can't really move that much they can't
decide where they're going so even if
you wanted to assert right-of-way
they're not going to be able to move but
then it really is aircraft that are
unpowered get to get the priority
there's also you know if you have
multiple aircrafts that are of the same
class so two airplanes two powered
airplanes coming at each other you know
how do you decide who has the
right-of-way so there there are some
situations which is basically that two
aircrafts that are converging that are
of the same category the aircraft on the
right has the right-of-way
so there are a couple of figures that
describe that so basically if two
aircraft er are looking head-on then you
both you both move to the right it's
good to have that rule of thumb yes the
blimp is a powered aircraft yeah it's
very slowly powered but it is powered
and so it is a powered aircraft if I
said balloon instead of blimp then the
balloon would have won the the balloon
sorry the blimp is is also frequently
called an airship
so the FAA question might refer to the
blimp as an airship okay so this was the
the right of way and then the yes so one
thing that that alters it is if you have
an aircraft that's landing and it's on
final approach to landing then it has
the right of way really to to land so
this is where we talked about the the
balloon has priority over all the others
the glider has priority over all over
powered aircraft the airship where the
blimp has the priority over all other
powered aircraft and then if you're
towing or refueling then you have that
priority as well so this is a little
diagram that shows you that it's very
unlikely that you will encounter an
aircraft refueling another aircraft so
one thing to know is also just minimum
safe altitudes so in general the real
you know you're the pilot in command you
need to ensure the safety of yourself
and your plane and your passengers so in
order to do that the biggest
consideration is that you're flying at
an altitude that's safe enough that if
something went wrong in your airplane
you would be able to land safely so it's
always good regardless of where you're
flying to keep an eye out on where's the
closest airport or where's the closest
you know flat clear fields that you
could land in and you want to be at an
altitude such that if you had an engine
failure you could make it safely to that
place and land safely so that's why even
though technically in some of this class
golf airspace you could be flying at you
know 100 feet above the ground unless
it's a very very flat desert where you
could land anywhere it's not a good idea
if you can't safely land over a
congested area which we talked about
it's kind of that yellow area on the
sectional you want you have to be higher
so the idea is just not to be a nuisance
when when it's very congested and then
do you want to talk to helicopters at
all helicopters can do whatever they
want is the ultimate rule of thumb yeah
actually your sorry your mic is over
here Mike Mike so basically the
helicopter just lives in the airplane
it's okay to lose the machine and
yourself
so you can fly over downtown Boston
quite low as long as you can always end
up in the Charles River for example but
you can't go below these there are no
arbitrary numbers you just say well I
could have Auto Club rotated to the
street or I could have Auto rotated into
the river and I wouldn't have destroyed
somebody else's build in your car so
that's that's what we look for
helicopters don't fly super low and
there's an FAA safety inspector actually
in your helicopter with another thing is
that it's very important that you just
you know you don't be careless or
reckless so you're not supposed to
endanger people's lives or property we
talked a little bit about placards and
how they can have restrictions on them
so this is what we mean by a placard so
they're just you know things that are
affixed to your airplane and it has some
instructions you know whatever it's
talking about these in particular for
example some of the never exceed speeds
are listed when you need to turn on a
strobe light is restrict is indicated
for example so I think it's really
interesting about dropping objects there
isn't
there isn't a rule that says you can't
throw stuff out of your airplane it just
says that you have to know what where
what you're throwing will land such that
it doesn't damage any property so
there's some interesting pumpkin
festivals around here that in the
October time frame they'll give you
pumpkins and you can even throw pumpkins
outside your airplane and try to hit a
giant X in the middle of a field and
there's no rule against it as long as
you know you don't damage any property
so it's kind of interesting formation
flight is kind of cool too
obviously you can't do anything that
would be hazardous but if you are in
communication with another pilot you've
decided in advance that you wanted to do
it you can do this so I actually had one
MIT flying club flight three airplanes
decided that that were part of the fly
out decided they wanted to do this
including myself and so we had three
three airplanes and we were nowhere near
as close as these planes are to each
other but we were in constant
communication with each other and we
were watching each other and it was
really cool to kind of fly together and
we actually landed as a flight so
instead of each having our own tail
number identified to an airport when we
were landing we picked an airport with
an extremely long runway I went our
controller and we said you know we want
to land as a flight of three and so they
gave us clearance and basically a Cessna
doesn't require that much space to land
you like to have 3,000 feet but 2,000
feet is pretty good and so this was a
runway that was over 8,000 feet long so
we had one person kind of landing at the
front one person at the back and the the
last person touched down before the
first person left so it's kind of a
formation flight only do this if you're
really comfortable with doing it you
could always decline and say no and make
sure that you are definitely
communication very good weather and you
only do this if it if it is a safe thing
to do you're in charge is the pilot of
command pilot and command P I see of
deciding whether it's a safe thing to do
or not there are also restrictions about
aircraft speed and the joke here is that
if you're flying an sr-71 you would
actually stall
even at 250 knots so you can fly as fast
as you want pretty much okay so landing
at an airport we discussed a little bit
about the runways and the runway
headings and so you know I think it's
just in terms of how did they number
that runway so what is runway 3 six mean
well it's really referring to three six
zero or pointing north
but it's rounded so in here like you
know it was actually three five eight
but they rounded it up to runway three
six and every now and again they update
these so you might see an airport change
its heading number because it's at
magnetic heading if there are more than
one runways that are parallel then they
they can say left so runway two one left
your runway two one right or C four
Center or if they have four runways
they'll usually just pretend that one's
at a slightly different degree than the
other ones so that you know one side
will be runway six left and six right
and then seven left and seven right even
though they're all basically parallel so
there are a lot of different runway
markings these kind of arrows here talk
about a displaced threshold so what are
the restrictions there so you can feel
free to taxi and take off on that space
but you're not supposed to land so
you're supposed to cross across that big
solid white line before you land right
here
so there are ton of different runway
markings again I encourage you even when
you're on a commercial flight to keep
your head out the window looking at all
the different lines that you see so you
can see the runway threshold you can see
the number of the runway that's that's
written there and then there are
different stripes that indicate how far
down you are you know a thousand feet
every 500 feet for example we talked
about the X what does X mean closed
don't land there the runways closed
so all of these are kind of defined in
the in the pee hack the pilots handbook
of aeronautical knowledge so I would
kind of refresh them some of them are
not very common one thing here is that
wind socks when socks are great there
are different kinds of wind socks it
basically tells you which direction the
wind is blowing in when it's a very
windy day or gusty day it's very
important to look at a wind sock because
even though it'll tell you you know for
example if you hear on the ATIS that the
the winds are ten gusting 25 that means
that the winds are 10 knots but
sometimes they gust up to 25 knots and a
gust can kind of change direction so
it's very important to know this and so
you might want to be looking at a wind
sock as you're as you're coming in or as
you're a being the runway and you want
to know which direction the winds going
in how much is it changing moving about
so that when you come in you're prepared
for that as you land there are other
types of wind indicators that are pretty
uncommon I doubt that you'll encounter
them but we've shown them here there's
also so the best way to fly is really
looking out the window and looking at
what the runway looks like it's a
picture of the runway so look at look at
it see what it looks like and that's the
best way but there's some things that
might trip you up like if runways are
wider or narrower than you're used to or
longer or shorter than you're used to
that it might appear to be a different
place than it is so it's always good to
have an indicator as a backup so there
are different glide slope indicators so
vazhi is one where there are these four
little lights you basically see them as
four lights and if you're too low
they're red and if you're too high there
they're all white but if you're right on
then about a thousand feet down the
runway so you basically use these as
you're coming in but once you can really
see the runway out the window yourself
you look out the window not at and you
look at the runway not at the these
glide slope indicators as you get close
so another variation is a poppy so I
like to think again with these memory
things vazhi I think vertical so that's
why there's some on top and some at the
bottom a poppy is the same thing but
it's horizontal they're also apparently
exists a tricolor visual approach slope
indicator almost no one uses this you
probably will never see it same with
this one but they exist
supposedly okay so we'll focus on things
you might actually hear so land and hold
short so we just talked about this who
remembers what land and hold short means
yes absolutely so you can land but don't
cross the intersecting runway unless
you're given permission so a land in the
hold short is something that the air
traffic controller might ask you to do
and they might be really assertive about
it and they might tell you know we have
a lot of traffic here I need you to land
and hold short regardless of how
assertively they tell you that you're
the pilot in command and you can just
you can just say no and they have to
deal with it so especially if you're a
new pilot you're actually not allowed to
accept a land and hold short instruction
as a student pilot so if you're a
student pilot they tell you to land and
hold short you have to say no and the
reason is that you may not be very good
at it and you might take more runway
than you thought you were gonna take in
order to land do you have a question no
okay and yet so you also have to have
proper visibility in order to accept
this type of restriction as well yes
it's okay to accept but you have to go
around you just have to you you do
what's safe for you first for your plane
and then you communicate that as quickly
as possible to the air traffic
controller if you as soon as you know
that you might have to go around you
need to communicate that so that they
can try to make sure that there's no
incident with the other aircraft but
generally you don't want to accept a LAN
and hold short unless you're you're very
comfortable with the environment you
know it's a good weather condition you
have a good handle of your aircraft your
air speeds doing what you want it to do
and and you feel comfortable that you
can actually follow that that guidance
but of course at the end of the day
you're the pilot in command and if it's
going to be unsafe to you and your
aircraft to make a landing and you have
to do it go around you have to do that
and you just need to communicate as
quickly as possible to the air traffic
controller so there's some there are
some light signals again no one's
probably ever encountered this in real
life but supposedly if your radio dies
and you need to communicate with the
tower they have this light gun and they
can communicate a bunch of information
to you via these signals there are great
candidates for FAA questions you're
unlikely to be used in reality and a lot
of people have their their checklist has
like a page in the back that has this
because it's so rare people don't
usually commit this to memory so here's
some more resources for you to refer to
all right are there any questions use in
conjunction with a coffee break all
right so it's about nice and I figured I
already saw people sleeping through my
last one
get two boxes of coffee all right it's
2:15 so we'll start up again at 2:30
you